OF THE NET.
HE SCORES.
TAKES IT OFF LESS
THAN TWO MINUTES INTO ORED FOR
DRIVES IT.
DROPS .
AND JB IS ON IT.
AND GETS A BUMP BY THROUGH.
FIVE MINUTES GONE IN THIS
TOP RIGHT.
>> THAT'S A
THERE'S A SEND MAKES A SAVE.
THERE'S A LOSE PUCK AND D A BON
BACK ON IT.
AND JUST FEELS LIKE
SOMETHING'S ABOUMIDDLE.
NICE LITTLE DROP PASS T DOWN LO
THERE IT IS.
SHATTENKIRK ABOUT THE LITTLE BU
WATCH AS HE
>> COMING IN RIGHT HAND SHOT.
HE GOT ALL IT
ADJUST.
THE CROSS PASS SURE BUT HIS
ABILITY TO GET TO THE RIGHT OF
THE SCREENIT
FIRST. OF START THE CLEAN EXIT.
>> HERE COMES SIDE OF THE GAME.
CERTAINLY 1-3. LARSSON TAKING
THE LINE.
HE STOPS THINKS ABOUOUCE  AY
GENERATE
SITUATION.
>> GHT T INT.
>> Leah: : WLER NDS S
A LOT T OF EDIT  RE  R R
BATTLING.
GREAT JOB B TTLE.
AND THIS  ALLY  O O FENSE E